[Music]
welcome to another episode of the addie
hour our first episode of 2022 i'm
honored and grateful to be able to
continue in these conversations with all
of you and to be able to engage with a
lot of thought leaders on really
important topics which is definitely the
case as well before we jump in just
wanted to step in or just start out and
say you know how encouraged i've been
the last few weeks and few months
honestly to have so many conversations
with so many of you who've shared how
you've been using these podcasts as
resources
for yourselves for family members for
friends who've had questions about
different aspects of mental health how
that intersects with aspects of our
faith and culture race and social
justice so it's been really encouraging
to me and also i'm a boost to be able to
keep these conversations as we engage in
a lot of these important topics and as i
mentioned that will definitely be the
case today i'm really excited and
honored to host dr mays ahmad on a very
important topic and timely topic of
trauma-informed teaching and learning
so by way of introduction dr mays ahmad
is someone who is an expert in this area
she received her undergraduate training
at the university of michigan dearborn
and then went on to phd studies in
cellular and clinical neurobiology at
wayne state university
dr ahmad was on the faculty at pima
community college for many years has
recently joined the faculty and is
teaching at connecticut college at the
moment
and dr amman's research really focuses
on stress self-awareness advocacy and
classroom community and how these
aspects impact student learning and
success she's someone who is a
nationally recognized leader in
trauma-informed teaching and learning
and she works with faculty all over the
country and in her specific institutions
across disciplines to really promote
inclusive equitable and contextual
education which is all rooted in
research
so dr aman is someone that i definitely
look up to especially with how she
continues to put mental health as a top
priority and is really helping us within
the education
realms to systematically support
education the education of the whole
student so i'm grateful to be able to
welcome dr mays ahmad to the addie hour
podcast thank you for being here
thank you for having me and thank you
for your kind introduction
of course it's a pleasure and an honor
in so many ways
uh and again you know as we're leading
things off starting out the year for
many who are involved in education you
know primary and secondary education
college education this is
the start again of a new semester or
starting after the holiday break um so
before we you know get into the topic at
hand just wanted to check in with you
that's where customers do and see
how you are navigating day to day at
this point in time as we get ready for
another semester
thank you for asking
um
surprisingly i've been
kind of at peace
with whatever is happening and the way
it's happening and
and um
i say surprisingly because
i
i recognize that i have
a certain
position and
certain
power to advocate for change and
sometimes i feel like i'm just
hitting a wall
and so
i would say the recent months i've been
surprised to see how much i'm just
sitting in the discomfort and learning
from it and
even finding peace
well that's really refreshing to hear in
a lot of ways i mean that's a topic i
think a lot of us talk about often
especially on our campuses you know
encouraging our students to be willing
to sit in the discomfort so to hear you
as a leader
and practitioner in a sense who is
saying the same thing i think also goes
a long way
but actually it makes it makes me think
also it's a process i mean the way you
just described that even being surprised
so
even though you teach it in a sense not
something that you necessarily
jumped into right away i mean would that
be an accurate statement absolutely oh
yes absolutely i mean i was um
i talked to with my students and
colleagues about you know the cortisol
spike and how to be careful
and yet as i talk with them about it i
think oh
and my cortisol spike so i know that
it's difficult
and so to watch myself
lean in i suppose or sit in the
discomfort and and and to just
allow it to teach me
i suppose
is rising yeah
now i imagine not that you haven't had
that um
empathy with your students before and
that
um
authenticity but i imagine that might
even take it to a whole nother level
um just what you describe too in terms
of how you talk about your own
experience with them and now again that
you haven't talked about that experience
in the past before but this sounds like
it's even in a different way in the
current moment as well
yeah yeah
i um as you mentioned i
you know mental health is something that
is
you know i advocate for i care deeply
something that is
um that is very much personal and i see
a
moral imperative there is
a human rights issue and
a few years ago i was working with uh
with a family member who was dealing
with that and i
the way
it was very much tough love
you find you you come across a challenge
tough love you you go through it you go
through the fire you
now
you know by the grace of god it
worked for me and i suppose
whether it did or not who knows
and so that's the framework that i was
using with that family member and
the person turned to me and said
tough love is not working it doesn't
work
and it was such a profound humbling
moment almost gave me an opportunity to
pause and say
that's right tough love is
tough and it's not always kind and
and so
um yeah those opportunities
those those moment of contradiction or
cracks or struggle or
or challenges they they also present us
with opportunities for growth
and
yeah
yeah what a great way to say it and i
mean that sounds like growth in the
moment as well so we allow that moment
to pause and say okay let me actually
hear what you're saying and not just go
into
my standard practice
so to speak and i think that's such a
such a huge component and it reminds me
of the work that you're you're doing in
this space already on so many levels
yeah
in that regard i also wanted to ask you
know for those who might not be as
familiar or familiar at all with
trauma-informed teaching and learning if
you could just define that um for
listeners as a starting point
yeah absolutely so i'd like to start
with definitions that we were on the
same page so when um so i'm going to
take the word trauma and we're talking
about
in this case psychological trauma and
much like physical trauma something
happens to somebody and there is a
reaction
so whereas a physical trauma perhaps i
trip
i trip on a nail i injure myself there
is a reaction internally in a
psychological trauma an event happens
that i perceive and i perceive it in a
way
when i say i i say i mean my nervous
system my body i perceive it in a way
that is
that's shocking
it is it is um overwhelming
it is threatening
and as a result our bodies our brains
are going to try to protect us so there
is a series of reactions that will
happen
in order to deal with that
so
what does that mean so for instance um
if i am
on my way to work and i
i witness or i myself
are involved in a car accident
our body knows danger
and sometimes it can't necessarily
distinguish between imminent and and
something that happened in past and
it will go into
a
this defensive mechanism of fight or
flight which is very physiological and
it will stay in that
and so even though the event has passed
the body hasn't quite metabolized that
event
so then in a trauma-informed education
what that means that i the educator i
have that awareness that trauma is
pervasive i mean
it impacts us it impacts how we show up
the impact how much
attention
and energy we can pay towards
for example solving a math problem so i
i
as the educator i have that awareness
and i also have that
awareness that there are things i can do
in my classroom
that can help the student feel
safe
connected
empowered those are all really powerful
ingredients to not necessarily heal
completely from trauma
but enables us to get
a new start if you will
that's a really helpful definition and
so many layers to it as well i mean from
the neuroscience side of things to the
awareness in the classroom to the
practices
as well and it seems that there's some
clear neuroscience tie-ins with your
background as a neuroscientist
so i did want to come back to the
awareness and practical pieces too but
before that just wanted to hear about
how you got into the work and whether
that was through neuroscience or through
other means or a combination like how
did this claim there are many
neuroscience who may not necessarily be
as attentive to this or thinking about
it on a daily basis
i think it was a combination i mean i
always say i am subject number one
and i
um
i am a refugee i am
i grew up in a country
that um
was bombed
i came to the country that
bombed my home
i
experienced death at an early age
i grew up in a war-torn country
now we didn't have the language
or the luxury to talk about those
feelings
so in undergrad i was
as a as a philosophy major i was really
fascinated by
why we
respond certain ways
why we do what we do and just just
what makes us
who we are
and
in
in graduate school as a neuroscience
student we really didn't learn about
trauma or emotion
in fact
what i often heard was that i'm too
emotional or i am
a mental
and i remember thinking if i could just
do something about my emotions i would
be
a brilliant scientist
so those are the and and i still see
those
nuanced messages in the academy that
emotions and
and and thinking are are not compatible
or emotions are the antithesis of
all
all the while i was experiencing
trauma and re-trauma the the invasion of
the iraq war of iraq my family is there
and what was happening is that it was
impacting how i showed up to classes
to
how i showed up to myself
but i had no idea i was even though
ironically i was a neuroscience student
i was not connecting the dots
and i would catch myself saying what's
wrong with me did i lose my intelligence
maybe i'm lazy maybe this maybe that not
making connections to
what's
in life
it wasn't really until i became a
teacher
in the classroom and i would catch my
students
experiencing similar things okay they
were not
um
in a war-torn country but they were daca
students they were
first generation students they were
displaced somehow and
these similar patterns and i started
having those aha moments that
how could they possibly
show up
holistically and fully
engage
um
with the complexity of learning
and not
bring everything else with them
so i began really my work
um as a way to
help empower them
to
to
pause
look if you failed an exam
it doesn't say anything about your
intelligence and brilliance and
it's just that at this moment you have
so much going on
and and that impacts how you show up
and so i started seeing the impact on
students on students sense of self
and in
in that process
i feel that
it has offered me
some healing myself
i started looking back and and
remembering key moments in my graduate
and i'm thinking that
oh
having empathy for
the the
the dramatized student
um who was stuck
yeah
so sorry that's all
to your question that's a great answer
too i mean the personal component is the
way it helps you really tune in
um i wonder if that was
if it felt
that's the right word
disenchanting at the beginning because
in some ways hearing you talk i'm
thinking about the research that was
already going on
in terms of the effects of trauma
but how that likely was not
incorporating any of that into the
classroom
so i mean you know as a neuroscientist
part of me thinks it could be very
frustrating to see all this work being
done elsewhere but not applied
in a key situation
where it needs to be but i wonder i mean
did you feel like you were building
something from the ground up in terms of
awareness or were there any others who
were i mean it didn't sound like there
were many who were paying attention to
it in this setting
at all yeah and just wondering what your
experience was like as you were trying
to bring this to the forefront
i think what was happening i was um
i was doing it quietly with my student
okay because of experience and because
of my experience and emotions and
and i think generally speaking in the
scientific community it's been my
experience that we don't we don't want
to deal with emotions they're sticky
they're
and so i was doing it um
quietly doing the research quietly with
my students and
whenever i would speak about it at
conferences or
i i would see
discomfort
right
because it's not it's not how we were
trained a lot of a lot of scientists
and so um but i did find
um
support from the k through 12. so the k
through 12 we're doing trauma informed
before before it became
something in higher education
and it was yes you are absolutely right
it was frustrating because i was
i i had the students experiences i had
my own experiences but also there was a
science
that was that wasn't is telling us that
wait a second
learning doesn't work in a vacuum
and so frustrating because i would
go to conferences read articles and i
think why are we not talking about this
i remember attending a conference
in july
of
20
2017
and the conference had
many tracks
active learning metacognition this and
that and the other and there was not a
single and it was about
stem
and there was not a single not a single
session about
what's going on with daca students
right now for me i was working close
many of them and i and i could see that
it was
that the socio-political situation was
impacting how they show up
and so for me to just go and say active
learning metacognition and this and that
and the other it's it's not it doesn't
take the whole context into account
there was serious trauma going on
so
yes frustrating but when you're working
with students and you see
how they respond and how they give back
it's
it's worth it
definitely in a lot of ways and i'm sure
that you've gotten that feedback from
students
over the years and then just seeing
i mean i'm thinking also just as you
describe the empowerment from that as
well just even that shift about what you
talked about earlier with the
grades not what's wrong with me but
being able to actually think back about
what happened to me and how is that
impacting
how moving forward i mean there's also a
sense of of
removal of blame in a sense and just
having that argument to move forward so
i mean on that note what are some of the
with some of the feedback that you've
gotten from from students and learners
as you've been
engaged in this work and really bring it
to the forefront
yeah so one that has been um i think
powerful for me
and also hearing from students
um
so so dr addy you're a neuroscientist
and you um
you you do this work
we we know that there are mechanisms
that are turned on or off when someone
undergoes trauma
now there's research that shows that
there's actually the the vestibular
system
is impacted and the vestibular system
if you if
it can impact our sense of being in
space our sense of agency and stuff
so i i've been fascinated with that
literature
and also thinking about when someone
experiences trauma our sense of control
or helplessness
feels
shattered
so
it's really important to cultiv
cultivate a space or an environment
where someone feels they have choices
options
agencies
this has been really in terms of
feedback from students this has been one
feedback i would say even more than when
they talk about safety the the sense i
have a say
i have agency
seems to be really powerful
in terms of helping students feel that
there is a way out
there's a way
rather
and so important and it's helpful to
hear what has been
kind of a
salient piece for students from their
perspective as well
on that note if we can shift a little
bit to kind of give people some of the
practical i'm curious if you can share
how you
encourage people to bring that awareness
into the classroom
as well because i mean i think that's
underlying a lot of what you've talked
about that the awareness just hadn't
been there maybe it had been in k
through 12 they've been in other pockets
but not in the classroom setting where
there's really the stigma of this
something that's wrong with you and it's
more about
deficits that you have as opposed to
what happened to you how do you how do
you shift or how have you been shifting
that
so i've been encouraging people to read
learn listen about trauma
including
intergenerational trauma
and my hope there is
to
you become the subject
you read or hear something and you think
i experienced that
and this
i experienced that
can then
help bring not just
awareness about me but about what who
else is experiencing that
and you know so i tell my colleagues i
tell family members and friends
you know if you're doing the laundry in
the background just have something
playing to
so you could learn about trauma learning
about the body why does it
and the reason for that is not just i
have awareness about what happens in the
body it's not it's not an academic
endeavor but it's really to help us
then recognize and have the
self-awareness when we're triggered when
we
what's going on what can we learn from
from that
and then and then i say what else what
do you think is happening with the
students
you know there there there's
there's things in the background just
like there are things in the background
for you
so i start with that i've been really
intentional to say learn about this it's
empowering
you know we tell students
knowledge is power knowledge is
empowering and knowledge can also be
healing because you
will listen and you think for me
certainly like ah
wait there's nothing wrong with my brain
it was just stuck
because of the event
and then
um i also encourage
colleagues to
on the one hand i say how would you like
to be
treated if you were the student in that
class
and more so i say talk with your
students
how do they
want to be treated
sometimes a lot of times we make
assumptions that the students know that
we care about them we have their back
but when things get tough
the brain
will go into this constricted narrow and
and and it may not be able to remember
so
let the students know that
i'm so excited you're in this class
we're on a journey together i have your
back
i am invested in your
success
repeat
keep that so it can become part of the
dna makeup of the class
and then um
learn about the students
learn about the human beings who are
um
and and learn in a variety of ways
perhaps a survey perhaps
email perhaps asking them to come and
meet with you
learning about them will then
enable i could give you a list of do's
and don'ts and you know i have
suggestion to offer
and at the same time it can't be a
one-size-fits-all because context is so
important
yeah
yeah i think that's really well said and
it makes me think about even as you know
you're going through your introduction
just the way that you
are seeking to educate the whole student
so i love the framework of really
learning about them as well because it
seems like also sometimes there's a
disconnect there between maybe what
instructors
feel that they're doing or want to do
versus what students perceive because i
can imagine situations where instructors
may say
just say things like oh we care about
how you're doing and we care about your
success but it's all within the
framework
of the academic achievement
as opposed to caring about you as a
person and you know just to share i mean
this is all anecdotal not not um
evidence based per se but just
the number of students who shared with
me in situations where we've talked
about
their feelings with everything that's
happened over the last few years and
students that i've never had
any professor actually create that space
to hear how i feel about the situation
or give a space to talk about so it
makes me think about your comments about
asking how they're doing whereas as an
instructor
instructor may feel well i gave those
opportunities by saying that i was
invested in them but it's a disconnect
between saying it and actually taking a
pause to invest and hear the feedback so
again i'm sure there's a lot you could
elaborate on that from from the work
that you've done but there's something
i've noticed you know just as engaging
with undergraduates and graduate
students over the years
yeah and it's it is foreign i remember
one time i asked my student
how's your heart
and it was what what physiologically
what what do you mean
and i had to i had to explain to them
what i mean by that and
um
and why it's so important to do that
checking in and and i started like
having a variety of
of ways of approaching and sometimes
asking the question how are you is so
tough i know that there are days when
you ask me that question
it's overwhelming i don't know how to
and so um i started for example saying
how bad is this monday
or using emojis and and actually a
student recommended emojis
and
but the point
is it's modeling
that you care enough to allocate the
time just like you did at the beginning
of this conversation
you know asking where i am how i am and
modeling and then pausing to
to um
to listen
yeah
yeah i think it's so important i also
appreciate the uh the sensitivity that
you mentioned in terms of the how are
you and how difficult that can be
at times i know sometimes people also
will give space to say
well it's fine if you don't want to
answer but i want to at least make that
option available because even thinking
you know back to the last few years with
several of my students of color in
particular i mean long before the
unfortunate situation with george floyd
but
just them often feel like they didn't
have the space for anyone to actually
check in and see how they were
when these certainties were happening so
even if they didn't want to share just
to know that okay someone actually
noticed
and took the time then maybe i can come
back to that later at least they felt
seen
in that moment as well and so again i
mean it just seems like so many of the
things that you're
trying to make sure that those really
come to the forefront and there is that
space
as well which i think is critically
important
definitely
yeah so i know you mentioned not
necessarily giving
all the practicals is not cookie cutter
even as you mentioned from your tough
love situation but are there general
kind of practical components that you do
like to
mention um to people who are in
classroom settings about what are some
of the practices once you have that
awareness to really kind of empower the
students and make sure that it's at the
forefront and
integrated
so um so let's start with options and
choices voice and choice it's really
important for
reminding students that they have agency
that they have a sense of
self
so how does how would this work so i
teach a physiology class
and in a physiology class i assign an
art as a scientist a research project
and i picked the topic
and it occurred to me
a few years ago why am i limiting the
topic
why if it's about what they are excited
about and what they feel connected
why don't i offer a series of
suggestions and then say and if you want
to come up with your own research
question work with me we will
and what i saw
when that happened when i did that
is
there was more investment in the project
because now it's like now i have this
kidney pain that is like comes and goes
i want to research that versus the
cookie cutter
um
one-size-fits-all
question
um
so that that's one the other thing is i
have um
flexibility is so important
and so
flexibility would be
we're in a pandemic
i mean i
i am
i am so proud of the students for just
showing up
it's overwhelming we feel overwhelmed i
feel overwhelmed sometimes it's hard to
get out of bed and yet they show
and they
and so we want to have positive
reinforcement so every class i make it a
point to give positive reinforcement to
the whole class ah you're here i'm so
excited today i had a class
and
all the students were there i thought i
was i was in seven heaven i thought
so that positive reinforcement matters
and at the same time
let the students know that life happens
and when life happens and you fell
asleep
and you couldn't
do the paper on time
because you were also i don't know
helping your father or something
come see me
we will work something out
there is a tendency among educators to
say all students are going to take
advantage of this and they're going to
i've never i've been teaching for i
don't know over 10 years
i've never had a student take advantage
of it
or even give me the sense that they were
taken advantage of on the contra when i
say
well do you want to take an extension
they have like a little bit of anxiety
no no no i'm going to fall behind this
month
so
talking about when life happens
flexibility it doesn't mean the students
are going to take advantage or take you
up on it but they know that there is
that comfort
so
um in addition to that i am
really before covid i'm really
intentional to
center
social and emotional and mental health
so one exercise or one of one practice i
do is that during the first or the
second week of the
of the semester i just talk very little
about social and emotional learning
where social
learning is holistic and so on
and i also invite someone from the
counseling center either the counseling
center or a therapist or
and i have a conversation with the
person and i say
things like
so you know
sometimes i get
really triggered what's going on
sometimes i'm sweating and i have
anxiety what's going on
and the person then
you know
well funny that you ask i'm so glad and
the person then gives a
you know a layman explanation of
mental health and why like physical
health we need to attend to it
and then i have this student program in
their phone
numbers
what do you who do you text when you
have anxiety in the middle of the night
there are free resources i want to
demystify it
i want demystified mental health i want
to also
um
please stigmatize it
i want to
show this
student that this is so important we're
going to have a session about this
this is also to preemptively have a plan
when things get really tough they have a
plan
now one thing i want to say about all of
these things is
it
it is there's a lot that the faculty
member is doing you know they're doing
their lesson plans they're doing their
lectures they're doing their grading and
also they're doing these emotional
giving
[Music]
and so it's a lot of work
and what i have experienced is that it
gives back
what do i mean by that when you look and
you see it your students feel
safe connected they're laughing they're
engaged they're
you look at it and you say oh this is
all worth it
it's it's it's i am
i am part of like
a tiny ripple effect that is going to
hopefully
make an impact
i love that ripple effect
comment as well because it ties
everything together which you mentioned
in just the um the back and forth that
can come from that as well it makes me
think also what you
talked about how those things can be
have a sense of healing for you as well
in your own process for us as
instructors and it's really important
yeah
i grew up in a tradition my grandma
used to use a lot of poetry
and i grew up in
her saying that we are each other's
mirror
and
the state of the students
wellness and the faculty wellness you
could
they're they're
they're very similar
there's
pain and anxiety and and even even
in some cases romanticizing despair
and yet
so i could look at the student and see
and you know
my own reflection and yet
i could use the power of the mirror
neuron to shift that
right it gives back to me
yeah yeah
definitely powerful
i love that you tied the neuroscience
back into
one question which i've had and i don't
know how much of this is in the field
which you start to touch on
all the importance at the level of the
student but just you know talking to you
know thinking about my own kids talking
to colleagues and their kids and
thinking about all the way through
college just
outside thinking about all the stressors
that the teachers
and the instructors are going through
and sometimes again this is all
speculation anecdotal but thinking that
even those individuals seem to be
operating a way where the stress is also
affecting them and how they interact in
the classroom and sometimes negatively
without maybe not necessarily
people being aware of it so i wonder
even as you were talking about mary are
there ways
that some of that awareness can also
happen
for instructors and for teachers to be
able to have some of that self-awareness
think about how it's also impacting how
they approach their students in the
classroom even as they're trying to be
attentive to the students as well
obviously that's a lot
to think about in terms of cognitive
load and emotional bandwidth but i'm
curious if that comes into play
in your work absolutely i mean secondary
traumatic stress is real
we have a lot of a lot of the literature
um
comes from the
um from healthcare workers and
volunteers that work with refugees and
immigrants
and again because we're so empathic we
we are like a sponge and so we pick
people some
uh stress and distress and and also
the the the helplessness feeling that oh
i want to help the student but i can't
and then it just it wears heavy on our
hearts
and in addition
we might be having our own
independent so they accumulate and then
it impacts as you said how we show up
and so i tell my colleagues i say do
this experiment actually don't do it i
mean i i don't advocate it but
go to the class sleep deprived
and see how much patience you have
and then ask the students
was i different
of course
in fact my students know when i'm having
a
a difficult day no matter how much
i work to mask it
so what that means is that you know this
whole notion of self-care is not just a
it's it's a necessity
if i am going to
want to continue to give and support and
show up holistically
for my students i have to
pause
i have to pause and take care and
replenish
however that is for for for
you yeah so important
and i imagine that self um that sleep
deprivation experiment has happened on
several occasions
yeah
which i am
i
i tend to if i'm sleep deprived and i
show up to class and um
and i actually it happened
it was so is perfect the way it happened
that i actually paused and i let the
students see what was happening
i they can ask me the same question
three four seven times and i just repeat
it and i make a
um you know
lighthearted comments of it
it was a day i was sleep-deprived
and they asked the same question and the
by the third time they asked it i had
this
why kidding me and and and i felt it and
then i let the students
look at what was going on
so
um
it is it is important that we
pay attention to how the educators are
and to empower them to take care of
their own
well-being to replenish and also parents
um
when i speak with my family members i
say what are you doing to take care of
you
so they could continue to help their
kids and
yeah
yeah
it's so important and encouraging this
to hear how you
incorporate it on both sides
which again makes me just think about
even
all the different things that you're
doing and just
i mean in terms of the research the
teaching helping your colleagues
informing your colleagues helping your
students and so
i can imagine i mean what are some of
your own
practices if if you're willing to share
just with everything because as you
mentioned there's a lot of
empathy that comes with that too and it
seems that it would be very easy for you
to be caring a lot i mean i know i can
say it from my own experience too in a
different space but
as you know talking with our bipod
students and faculty sometimes all that
weight can
sit if there's not ways to at least
process and manage that before the next
event or the next mentoring session or
the next teaching
session so i'm just curious for you how
how do you
go about that on a day-to-day basis
so i um i can't regulate what i don't
know
and so the self-awareness is so
important tuning in
and um
i started paying attention to i i know
where the pain shows up
and when i have not or
when i feel i'm
just really um
tense
it's an indication because i documented
it i wanted to if there is
an indication that i am just going going
going no pausing no pausing no
processing no replenishing
and and then i just
i mean it's really interesting
i think let me just go one more day
i'll take time this weekend or the next
weekend and it reaches a point where for
me
my body says you're not gonna stop i'm
gonna make you stop
okay
and it shows up in the form of really
migraine headaches or tension headache
or this or that where i'm no longer
effective doesn't matter how much
what
so
what i what i started doing i
have to hold myself accountable and so i
have a group of
friends
family members
that they check up with me we check up
on each other and we feel comfortable
saying
um
i've been doing too much
or what are you doing to take care of
yourself and
and they can tell when i when i'm when
i'm
not answering
um fully
um
i also learned
what helped me what helps me replenish
and
for me it's disconnecting and it could
be for half an hour only
i remember a mentor saying to me take
five minutes
and initially i thought five minutes
what is five minutes gonna do five
minutes if it becomes a routine and it's
just for you and you just focus on
focusing on i don't know breathing or
dancing or something
is is powerful
and
for me i
every day in my calendar
i allocate
a half hour and that half hour
i don't use the phone or the computer or
i just i do something
with nature
even if it
i was in detroit
visiting my family
and it was snowing is and it was
and i would
practically put every layer
i had on so i could go outside just for
that half an hour
yeah
and it was remarkable how much it it
just it helped me re-center
um so i could show up again and and
to
to offer the space for others to
to work through and move forward
yeah yeah such an effective practice
and it's also encouraging that it's full
circle because it's the self-awareness
that you're also
encouraging others
to apply in the classroom
so sometimes you know when we are trying
to
share insights with others it's
difficult to apply it to ourselves
so that's also
encouraging
i think it's important to
um
normalize those practices so i
not too long ago i went to
visit my doctor
well i had a doctor's appointment and um
the doctor actually was coming on her
day off but because i was in when i
and
she said
would it be okay with you if we take
three minutes to just do a breathing
exercise
i said okay i don't mind so
we sat uh and in the office and we did a
breathing exercise and later she said
you know this is more for me i'm
i'm i'm having an off day and i i just
before i could give i needed to do this
wow it was
it was really i mean i was
i felt healed before she talked about my
my my blood work i was like i don't need
to know anything i'm i feel good
no
wow that's so so powerful and
encouraging i mean i've never
had that type of experience in a
doctor's office but it goes such a long
way and it makes it full circle too
because i have had
you know students
who have shared that with me before
share that with other people like you
said if someone comes sleep deprived
there's something going on they're just
not their autumn themselves that day
just for them to hear that from us
goes such a long way and the way you
just characterize that so i think
brought it home in a way that's hard to
sometimes conceptualize when you're the
one
sharing those pieces but just to have
yeah that's that's amazing
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i can continue to learn from each other
i'll go ahead yeah
i i do an exercise with students um
it's called
a silent visit with yourself and so i
talked with them about
um
the
just the nervous system and how the
nervous system sometimes goes into
autopilot and so
work school and then you know class
class class
and so what i do
really it's a one minute exercise at the
beginning of the class and i say
take a minute
to
just pause and remind yourself why
being here today is important for you
and so you know students they sit
sometimes they close their eyes
sometimes but they're they're there
they're present the whole thing is about
and
i had to miss class one time
and i told the students there's going to
be
a someone who will cover from me and so
on
and
the students were not concerned that i
was going to miss class they were
concerned with
what about the one moment
is the can we still do the one moment
and i was so touched that they that was
so important for them
and later on i asked them to give
feedback and they said that really
helped them there's something about
talking with their brain
negotiating with the brain that helps
them focus on the what's to come
so
yeah
yeah that's that's really encouraging
here and it seemed like the practice it
stuck
but it was good in a way maybe it was
good for them to be able to have you
gone to say okay well we can also
incorporate this
ourselves
even without doing without you around
which i guess is a measure of success
for you as well to really have it
integrated
yeah
this has been so refreshing in a lot of
ways maybe in some surprising ways you
know if people are tuning in and
thinking about trauma-informed teaching
not necessarily expecting to have a
sense of uh refreshing
aspects in it with some of these
practices but i think there's there's so
many things that are full circle things
that we can learn from our students and
that
can be vice versa to really kind of help
us all be in a better place holistically
so again that really ties into what we
do on the podcast
i appreciate you being here to share
that but did also want to close and i
know you talk about hope in your work a
lot too just having you share what gives
you hope in the work that you do and
even as we continue to move forward
yeah
um thank you that's a
brilliant question
i would say
young people give me hope
the students
their
their desire to learn their desires to
do right by by their fellow students
their
honesty and compassion
for me
i've i've
i talk about the classroom as a
sanctuary and it has
weary for me
and
the the
the kindness and the
grace my students have
have just
given me over the years that gives me a
lot of hope
um
people are resilient we are resilient we
rumi says
you are not a drop in the ocean you're
the entire ocean in a drop
and we all are that and
we um sometimes lose touch with that and
it's
the
community the
[Music]
our fellow human beings that that remind
us of wait a second i i
um i do matter
and you do matter
and so and we move forward so
there's a lot
to um
to
sure
there's a lot of pain
and and
and trauma and anxiety
and i will never undermine it
and grief and sorrow
and at the same time
there are
pockets of of remarkable
beauty and love and and those give me
hope
so well said
and a lot of ways ties back to community
as well i mean just to be in a community
to be able to
engage and
have that sense of hope as you see the
students passions and enthusiasm and as
you see their resilience so a lot of
ways that's that's really encouraging to
hear while acknowledging the realities
as well
so
absolutely
well thank you again for being here on
the addie hour very rich uh conversation
which doesn't surprise me in the least
and just grateful for the work that you
continue to do and just for the impact
that you're making i know the ripples
are continuing and they'll continue for
quite a while and i'm excited to see how
things continue to move forward for you
in so many important ways
thank you so much thank you for the work
you do for advocating for
mental health and and i'm i'm really
grateful to have spent this past hour
with you
and your
audience so encouraging thanks so much
[Music]